hi guys scifi recapped here
before we start warning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2019 american science fiction and action
movie called gemini man
the movie begins with a professional
sniper named henry brogan who is hiding
out in the field in belgium and is
preparing everything before pulling the
trigger to kill a suspected terrorist
valerie dormoff who is enjoying his time
on a moving train
he is helped by a fellow dia agent
mourinho who keeps informing henry about
the current situation on the train
when he is ready suddenly a girl comes
to dormoff preventing him from releasing
the bullet after she is out of sight
henry immediately shoots and it seems
like the bullet hit the target just
before the train runs into the tunnel
after the event mourinho tells him that
he was impressed with the shot as it
perfectly strikes the target in the neck
he even records the incident with his
phone which henry immediately orders him
to delete
after the assassination henry feels
remorse and decides to retire from the
risky job as it keeps haunting him
before sleep
not long after he is visited by dell
patterson
he tells him about how one wrong move
could have ended the innocent girl's
life and expresses his retirement plan
to him hoping that he will gain some
peace for not killing a person again he
then rents a boat where he meets danny
an agent who disguises an administrator
he uses the boat to catch up with jack
who later reveals that dormoff was not a
terrorist but a molecular biologist
turns out the file henry read about him
was being spiked so he demands to speak
with jack's informant yuri to clarify
everything meanwhile the encounter in
the whole conversation is bugged by dr
director janet lasseter and gemini ceo
clay varus
realizing that henry might be knowing
classified information
klay teams up with lasseter to eliminate
the sniper as they are afraid that he
will be a threat
back to henry he feels something strange
at the boat and finds a wire plug there
he immediately confronts danny and
suspects her of being dia spy
she denies the accusation as she manages
to answer his questions smoothly henry
feels guilty and apologizes then he
invites her for dinner
henry eventually finds out danny's real
identity who turns out to be one of diaz
agents
she is surprised and admits that she is
dia
after the dinner they split up as danny
says that it might be their last
encounter
later that night jack's boat is invaded
by lasseter's henchman who kills jack
and his girlfriend
soon after henry wakes up from his sleep
realizing that someone sneaks into his
house
he immediately warns mourinho to flee
from his house but it is too late as he
hears him getting killed over the phone
he equips himself and heads over to
danny's place he concludes that she is
not involved in the operation thus she
might also be in danger now
danny goes to the harbor to find a boat
where she is attacked by a mercenary
however she can't be underestimated as
she manages to defeat the man while
acquiring the information about his
sender
not long after henry arrives at the
harbor where danny reveals to him that
lasseter sent the killers
they decide to work together and escape
from there with a stolen boat
the next day henry is still clueless
about what is happening while waiting to
be picked up by baron henry's old friend
meanwhile clay is disappointed with
lasseter's men's performance so he tells
her that gemini will handle the sniper
from now on
henry calls dell who reveals that gemini
and lasseter are the perpetrator and he
has no authority to stop his superior
turns out that dormoff used to be one of
gemini's researchers and killing him
indirectly forces clay to make a move
danny tells henry that gemini is a
privatized paramilitary specialized in
kidnapping and torturing specific target
owned by clay varus who turns out was
henry x superior and tried to hire him
and barron to join gemini but rejected
by them
the trio then traveled to colombia
temporarily where the sniper tells them
that he had history with clay
the next morning henry wakes up and
spots another sniper sneaking across the
adjacent rooftop he lures the sniper
away so that danny and baron can escape
safely after exchanging some shots he
soon realizes that the foe or called
junior looks exactly like him but
younger
surprisingly junior also possesses the
same skills as henry acting like he is
his doppelganger because of that henry
struggles to defeat him
henry tries to escape with the stolen
motorbike but junior keeps chasing him
from behind also with a stolen motorbike
after a long chase junior hits henry and
he falls off the bike
just before junior attempts to kill him
the local police arrive and arrest henry
while junior manages to escape
thanks to danny she releases him not
long after the incident
henry and the team travel to budapest to
meet yuri dell's informant to get more
information about the current situation
on their way danny also notices junior's
similarity with henry but he refuses to
believe that he is his kid or whatsoever
it is on the other side junior returns
to clay's house to treat his wound the
kid is impressed with henry's skill but
he still doesn't realize their
similarity especially the face
clay tries to calm him down making him
feel like clay's beloved son afterwards
the ceo shows junior gemini's
mercenaries training session and then
sends him to budapest to continue his
mission
upon arrival dany meets his connection
aniko and gives her the samples of
junior to do a dna test
she later informs the other that junior
is indeed henry's clone since both of
them have identical dna
this fact leaves henry bewildered the
trio meet yuri at his place where he
reveals that dormoff worked on gemini's
cloning project and it is revealed that
henry took part in the experiment yuri
adds that henry was sent to kill dormoff
because he made a breakthrough but clay
and dormoff had a descent as clay wanted
a cloned soldier without conscience and
pain thus dormoff walked out from the
project
they then proceed to the next plan henry
sends a messenger to blackmail lasseter
who reads her everyday routine that
makes her terrified
afterwards he calls lasseter and
negotiates with her telling her to bring
junior to him in exchange for danny's
safety
they agree with the terms and lasseter
immediately arranges the meeting
that night junior meets danny alone in
the garden where he examines her to
ensure she is not wearing a wire
he breaks the agreement then takes her
to a tunnel while ordering henry to meet
him there if he wants danny to survive
upon arrival junior sets a grenade trap
on the entrance
henry breaks in and manages to avoid the
grenade trap
he gets junior cornered and frees danny
he feels the connection with junior and
refuses to kill him but will do it if
necessary he reveals to the kid about
who clay really is as well as junior's
real identity since they share the same
allergies to bees habits and the empty
feelings of not killing someone
junior still doesn't believe him so
henry is forced to reveal the real truth
he tells junior that clay took his blood
25 years ago and used it to create
junior to replace henry as he is getting
old
the kid starts to hesitate but still
doesn't want to accept the truth
they then fight again but henry
prohibits danny from shooting junior
the kid almost kills henry before danny
intervenes
junior escapes while the trio
immediately head over to georgia to
confront clay jr returns to gemini hq
and forces clay to tell him the truth he
does tell him revealing that it was a
necessary lie to him to grow stronger as
expected he also gives him sweet words
such as daddy cares and loves his son a
lot
as soon as the trio arrive at georgia
junior appears and poisons henry with b
venom which he is allergic to but later
neutralizes him with epipen
the kid believes henry and decides to
team up with them to take clay down
henry shares to the kid about his
personal life in his past
he encourages him not to follow his
miserable life and find a good life
purpose
as they drive to a nearby town clay
calls junior ordering him to escape the
car
turns out a tank has been waiting for
them and fires a missile towards their
car
unfortunately baron is killed but the
others managed to jump out of the car
a few moments later a group of gemini
soldiers arrive at the town and are
ready to ambush them
there is also a masked soldier who
starts shooting them with a machine gun
henry and danny team up to eliminate the
soldiers one by one
they later are cornered since the
soldiers keep coming and they decide to
hide in a house
danny is shot in the leg and they are
out of ammo
meanwhile junior confronts his adoptive
father telling him to withdraw the
attack clay tells him that killing henry
is necessary but junior finally refuses
to obey the order and attacks clay
he eventually manages to knock clay out
and runs to help henry and danny
he arrives on time and eliminates the
emerging soldiers
after everyone is eliminated the armored
and masked soldier confronts them
shooting them with specialized weapon
it's a three versus one situation and
the soldier is immune to bullets
surprisingly the soldier is also immune
to fire after dany tries to burn him
down
left with no option junior grabs the
weapon and starts shooting at him
ruthlessly until he is taken down
they take off the mask revealing that
the soldier is another clone of henry
but at a younger age than junior
clay regains his consciousness and finds
the others
he tells henry that he should be
flattered because he was the inspiration
behind all this
he tells them that the real purpose of
creating gemini is to produce perfect
soldiers that feel no pain and fear thus
no americans have to die again due to
wars
junior points his gun at clay attempting
to kill him but henry stops him as he
doesn't want him to feel the same
remorse and trauma from killing people
he grabs the gun and kills the ceo
himself
the gemini program is subsequently shut
down and every clone has been taken care
of at the end of the movie henry meets
danny at the college where junior now
has changed his name into jackson brogan
which is henry's mother's maiden name
finally has his official identity and
intends to pursue his future in the
engineering world
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching